what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down today I have a special
guest uh Janice fiamengo um she is a
professor a former professor of English
at the University of Ottawa Canada an
avid follower of the anti-final feminist
movement Free Speech Advocate and
defender of men's rights and you started
your career in 2009 as a professor at
the University of Ottawa welcome to the
show
hey thanks very much for having me on
your show
so
um tell me what what got you into like
anti-feminist
s
have you have you always been an
anti-feminist or like when what started
this
yeah this could take up the whole time
so I'll try not to be too long-winded I
was actually a feminist
um even I would say I was a radical
feminist I um you know I went to
University I did all my degrees at the
University of British Columbia and
um from the time I was quite young I I
really wanted to be an English Professor
I wanted to teach literature and so I uh
I I did my undergraduate degree I think
it was pretty non-political I I don't
remember like I went I started um
university in 1982. so
um the universities were already then
becoming politicized but not to the
extent that they have been now but all
of the social justice series Marxist
theory critical race Theory feminist
Theory eco-criticism you know all of
those were becoming respectable ways of
looking at the world and they were being
promoted in in Academia but I had a
pretty non-ideological undergraduate
degree but when I became a graduate
student I was quite attracted by all of
those theories and um
and I and you know no one I I never
heard uh an anti-feminist presentation
I never heard anti-feminist ideas taken
seriously at University so I became a
feminist not because of any
um you know personal experience of
Oppression or feeling that I was made to
feel inferior as a woman you know
definitely not like I I'd had
super supportive
men in my lives in my life you know very
supportive mentors I had a wonderful
father that I loved very much and
um but but uh I was attracted by radical
feminist Theory and and I think it's
a very seductive sort of world view it
it gives you a sense that you're this
righteous victim
and that uh
you're you you have a kind of it gives
authenticity and moral innocence it
gives you a cause it gives an identity
and a collective sense of solidarity
with other allegedly oppressed peoples
and it I I found it very attractive so
while I was doing my graduate work I'd
identified as a feminist and I did a
feminist PhD thesis on 19th century
mostly Canadian women writers and early
20th century Canadian women writers
and while I was
studying those women and reading their
works I did begin to have certain kinds
of doubts because the feminist
perspective is that you know women up
until a certain point you know were
voiceless and disempowered and
um you know living under intolerable
oppression but it was pretty obvious to
me reading I read journalists and
essayists and some of them worked as
teachers religious leaders one of them
was a religious philosopher as well as a
crusader for all sorts of causes such as
the temperance movement and the decent
treatment of animals and improved
factory conditions for for working-class
people this was a woman who was writing
in the 1870s and 1880s and she was a
very important person and her words
mattered she wrote in all the major
Canadian and American periodicals and I
had to admit that she wasn't oppressed
she didn't see herself as oppressed
although she did advocate for some
women's causes
uh and I you know I read other other
feminists who were similarly situated in
or sorry not feminists but uh some of
them were moderate feminist writers but
other woman writers who who
they they were making an impact on their
culture and they their lives were quite
full and quite free and so you know my
feminism was already being modified at
that point but I still would have
identified as a feminist when I got my
first job at the University of
Saskatchewan after I graduated with my
PhD that was when things really
yes the house of cards of feminist
ideology sort of fell apart in that
I I think I I felt ashamed actually in a
way to be standing up at the front of a
classroom and teaching from a feminist
perspective as most people did
and looking out at the few young men
that were left in my classes because
English classes tended to be
predominantly women probably about 80 20
women to to men and you know I was
looking out at these young men and I'm
just thinking what it must be like to be
a young man in a university classroom
and having to sit there class after
class and hear the same line whether you
were taking literature or sociology or
criminology
or religious studies or art history you
know that the entire world was a world
of men dominating women and that men
were responsible for all the bad things
in the world their sex was responsible
for war and inequality and poverty and
Injustice and violence and that what
they had to do now is sort of in
recompense for all the damage that their
sex had done was that they had to take a
step back and or 10 steps back and
essentially let their sisters take over
because their sisters were by definition
morally Superior innocent of any
responsibility for wrongdoing and
capable of much Superior leadership
because women were supposedly more
empathetic and more collectivist and
more egalitarian and had better
leadership skills you know Etc all the
stuff that we still hear today Ad
nauseam and that was you know very much
the Orthodoxy when I was teaching I I
got my first job in in 1999 so nearly 25
years ago but but that was the the
Orthodoxy and I you know I I just
started to think how horrible that must
be that even if it were true that up
until just a few years ago you know man
had ruled the world
that you know even if that were true it
was a horrific Guilt Trip a ridiculous
burden to lay on the shoulders of a 19
year old guy at University many of whom
at the University I was teaching at you
know came from poor farming families and
they even if some men were responsible
for hideous Injustice these guys and
their fathers certainly were not and I
also began to doubt that standard line
because you know the more I read into
history or or just thought about things
the actual facts of war or the actual
facts of how civilization had been built
in the West
you know it was obvious to me that men
had not intended to oppress women that
men had sacrificed to to build a safe
and secure Society for their they're
women and their children and that men
had borne many burdens on their
shoulders of killing work that wasn't
necessarily fulfilling in any way and uh
you know of of terrible responsibilities
so yeah the the the whole ideology
really began to to crumble for me and
um so at that point I stopped really
identifying as a as a feminist I didn't
you know vehemently object but I I
realized I didn't want to teach
literature through a feminist framework
I didn't want to
proselytize to my students and um but it
took about another 10 years or so before
I really decided that I wanted to speak
out on behalf of men and you know during
that time I could just see that the
demonization and the dehumanization of
men was
was
uh just a almost
incredible Injustice that so many people
allowed to pass it seemed that nobody at
the University or in the wider Society
cared about men
and and I was actually like I couldn't
believe that men put up with it and you
know the the feminist message was always
that these men were you know they were
privileged they were entitled they they
um
they they felt that they deserved access
to women's bodies that they had grown up
in a rape culture that told them that
dominating and oppressing women was a
pleasurable thing to do and that we
needed to lecture them about that we
needed to tell them that women didn't
owe them anything we needed to make sure
they got consent at every stage of a
sexual encounter because if they didn't
they deserved to go to jail you know and
on and on and I could look at these
young guys and it was just evident that
it wasn't so that they were not
privileged and entitled they were
often shamed
and uncertain about whether they were
even allowed to speak about certain
issues
and I I just thought that that again
even if it had been true that previous
generations had been you know of men had
been entitled and privileged like why
should that be visited on a generation
of young men who weren't responsible for
that and like it just became obvious to
me that it was a kind of class Vengeance
that was being uh enacted so
so in 2012
I saw um that there was a protest at the
University of Toronto against
a men's rights Advocate named Warren
Farrell and I don't know if you you know
him
um he's written a lot of really
interesting books about men's issues and
the most famous one is called the myth
of male power I would really recommend
it to anybody who's interested in an
introduction to men's issues and he had
been a feminist himself but he was
turned off he was involved in the
National Organization for Women and with
various feminist groups but he got
turned off by the Rabid anti-male
animus that permeated the feminist
movement so although he had never become
in any way like he wasn't an
anti-feminist I wouldn't say I don't
think he would call himself that to this
day but he
he he's really skilled at presenting
what all these issues look like from
from the man's perspective and so he was
speaking and he's become very interested
in the the situation of boys and young
men and the all the problems that boys
are having in school because the entire
teaching of of of uh you know from
elementary school right up has been
transformed to favor girls most teachers
are women of course most teachers are
feminists they believe that part of
their job as teachers is to encourage
girls many of them don't really like
boys and aren't particularly interested
in the way boys learn they see boys as a
problem in the classroom they think that
you know boys have had it too good for
too long so maybe it's time for boys to
sit down and and be quiet and uh so so
uh so he he's you know really addressed
a lot of these issues and he was invited
to speak at the University of Toronto
which is one of the major universities
in Canada
and he was invited by a group called
Cafe the Canadian Association for
equality which is a a group that's
that's interested in men's and boys
issues and and he was prevented from
speaking for about an hour and a half by
a rabid mob of feminist students who
gathered outside the building where he
was supposed to speak and prevented
people from going in they formed a human
chain around the building so that nobody
could get into the the room where he was
going to speak and you know they chanted
uh they gave the Heil Hitler salute to
the security guards who came to try to
keep order they they shouted verbal
abuse at the few people that were still
there trying to to get into the uh the
event and it was just like a ridiculous
display of
um pro-feminist anti-male hysteria and
when I saw that that was sort of like
the straw that broke the camel's back I
I that was in the fall of 2012 and I I
just thought
like this is what campuses become a
place where even a moderate person
wanting to talk about the Troubles of
boys is somehow seen to be a rape
apologist or a promoter of the
patriarchy and it was so clear that none
of the students who gathered there and
there were maybe 40 or 50 students
causing this Ruckus I'm sure not a
single one of them had ever read
anything by Warren Farrell they'd been
egged on by the professors of their
women's studies courses they've been
given a few phrases of ferals taken out
of context from a previous book that
he'd published which allegedly made him
a rape apologist and they were spouting
these few phrases and knowing absolutely
nothing else about him or what he stood
for and so I really realized that the
universities had been taken over by an
anti-scientific
anti-scholarly ideological called Dogma
that would Brook no descent and wasn't
the least bit interested in truth and
certainly not in equality so I contacted
the Canadian Organization for equality
at that point and I said that I I was
interested in being involved with them
in any way that they'd be interested in
in you know having me be involved and I
at that point I thought maybe I could be
a mentor for for guys at University like
I was at the University of
Ottawa by that point and um
so I I was a little ways away from
Toronto but I thought um perhaps if
there were young men at the University
of Ottawa who were having trouble in
some of their classes and and you know
these classes are places where men are
shamed men are humiliated they are made
to feel that they're somehow uniquely
guilty for the you know sins of the
world and they should have to apologize
for that in their person and so I you
know and if they don't toe the line of
feminist Dogma if they try to argue
against what their teacher is promoting
or if they try to write their papers in
a non-feminist manner that can cause all
sorts of problems for them and so I
thought I could maybe just speak to
those guys and try to help them through
the experiences that they were having
and at that point then the Canadian
Association for equality invited me to
speak at the University of Toronto and I
went there in the spring of 2013 and
there was a protest again and they
pulled the fire alarm and and uh
pardon me they protested you
oh yeah yeah yeah they protested me they
had posters up all over the place saying
you know I was gonna make the campus
unsafe for for women you know I would be
somehow yeah you seem very terrifying
you would be yeah yeah well and you know
but it is terrifying to these ideologues
if anyone criticizes the Orthodoxy and
that's what I was talking about I was
talking about women's studies as uh
um a fake academic discipline
and my point was that that gender
studies programs really have no part of
a self-respecting university they
shouldn't be allowed
into a university because they aren't
interested in knowledge they are not
about pursuing truth they're not about
women's studies like a women's studies
course that was genuinely academic would
look at the experience of women
throughout history they would look at
Women's cultural production they would
look at Women's art you know from a
variety of perspectives they would aim
to be objective yeah you know they would
they would include uh information about
uh evolutionary biology the findings of
evolutionary biology and how women have
evolved over time you know they would
look at all sorts of things from a
variety of perspectives they would not
have an ideological agenda the point
would not be to portray women as
oppressed victims and to inculcate
students with revolutionary ideals uh
and you know misinformation about
women's real position in society so that
was my the argument I was making and
um yeah that's that was unacceptable and
I was also of course including some
reflection on the Injustice to young men
at University today and yeah that was
that was that was very dangerous and and
since then I I've given a number of
talks at universities almost all of them
have been protested I tried to give a
talk at my own University in 2014 and it
was
shut down completely uh it never did get
completed we had to we changed rooms the
protesters went into the new room that
we that we found uh they wouldn't let me
speak and it's such an interesting
position because you see
the the utter power the absolute power
of these people who are pretending that
they're powerless they have the power to
shut down a talk
and the security wouldn't do anything
about it it was clear that they they
didn't feel they couldn't even touch the
students so the students had carte
blanche to prevent the talk from going
forward meanwhile of course they're
posturing as as victims and you know it
it's so ironic because
it would never be allowed to happen in
the reverse if a feminist Professor was
giving a talk about you know the
problems facing girls in our society
a men's issues group tried to shut it
down or a conservative Club protested it
they would be hauled away like you know
they'd they'd be handcuffed and put in a
Paddy Wagon immediately I've seen
students
just protesting abortion on University
campuses put in paddy wagons and taken
away simply for not bothering anyone
standing holding signs with images of
aborted fetuses and that is so
unacceptable on a University campus that
those students are hauled off in a Paddy
Wagon but
Marx's students the Revolutionary
student Society they can they can shut
down a talk an anti-feminist talk or
talk about men's issues with impunity so
um yeah so that was my sort of
introduction to the world of
anti-feminism and
men's issues and um it's been all uh
interesting ever since then I I started
a YouTube channel on critiquing feminism
and I I retired in 2019 I took early
retirement because I didn't feel like
the University was really a place that I
wanted to to be in the ideological
Conformity there is is quite striking
and
um my YouTube channel got shut down
uh I forget what year that was I think
in 2020 or 2021 I've started up another
one
um it's not really my channel it's my my
friend uh Steve brulee's Channel because
I don't know how to do any of the
technical stuff just like we were
talking about
um and it's it's uh I'm uh essentially
doing a history of feminist thought and
I'm I'm now writing a book on the
history of feminist thought as well just
to show that
even if you simply read the texts that
were written by all the major feminist
figures going back to 1792 and coming
right up into the present there's no way
that you can make the argument that
the feminist movement in any of its
phases or waves whatever one wants to
call them you can't make the argument
that that movement was ever about
equality
it was never about social justice
it was always
hateful it was it it always had a
intense repugnance for maleness itself
especially for male sexuality
and it always had uh corresponding
conviction of female superiority that
runs throughout all the texts that is
quite startling and so whenever I hear
people say oh well it started off as a
good movement you know it was it was
reasonable the first wave or some people
even say the second wave was reasonable
that was just about destroying sexist
stereotypes and then it went wrong in
1970 or in in the 1990s like there's
always a point at which it went wrong
and it got miss you know misapplied or
but it never was if you if you read Mary
Walston crafts a Vindication of the
rights of woman or you read Elizabeth
Elizabeth Katie Stanton's Declaration of
Sentiments where you read any of the
tracks about marriage and prostitution
that were written in the mid to late
19th century or you read anything about
the suffragettes
like it's it's it's
startling the radicalism of even those
very early writers they hated the family
they they they wanted to destroy the
family they promoted free love They
promoted the idea of children being
raised in collectives so that women
could be freed from the burdens of
raising their own children uh they were
often influenced by Marxism
and that's there right from the
beginning so yeah so that's what you
know I'm I'm kind of interested in
exploring that's my my main focus and
and men's issues too because
um
yeah I'm really I'm really concerned
about
all men but especially young men today
like the laws
are so biased against men
um marriage is such a risk now for for
guys and
um
the problem of false allegations false
accusations
like feminism has really successfully
destroyed the presumption of innocence
uh the the right to due process
and
and when you talk to
feminists like on Twitter or wherever
they're just not
they're not honest about any of these
things they're they're you know they
they won't
they won't argue in good faith they
and they're and their lack of empathy
for for men that because they have this
conviction that as a woman they are they
are the Righteous oppressed therefore
they don't have to care about men at all
and I've seen that so often in when I've
given talks like a woman I'll give a
talk talking about
all the issues that are facing young men
today
the fact that they're you know they're
at 40 percent in University they're
falling behind women in skills
acquisition in employment in real wages
in job status
um you know they've been discriminated
against in affirmative action and Equity
hiring for 40 years they're vulnerable
to false accusations sexual harassment
policies and workplaces discriminating
against men all the time you know their
their ability to defend themselves
against a claim of rape or sexual
assault is being chipped away at you
know year after year in the Law Courts
like there's so many issues
paternity fraud
um and I'll give a talk about those
things
and a woman will stand up
after the talk and say
well in 1982
a man put his hand on my thigh at you
know and told me I'd be better off to be
staying at home having babies rather
than working in the law office
and you know and people will applaud her
for saying that and it's like so what
what is your point because one thing
happened to you and I'm like lady get
over it whatever you know and like
it's it's so striking like that
entitlement that that so many women have
it's yeah it's it's amazing I gotta I
got a couple questions I wrote down some
notes so okay why is it so bad in the
schools like why is gender studies
so why is the history so manipulated
with like your experience being in the
education system like if you brought up
um like I I just found out the other day
that the first female property owner was
in the 1600s which kind of goes against
like you know the feminist in the US
anyway I don't know what it was in
Canada but um which goes against like
the feminist narrative so like why isn't
that stuff like taught in schools
because you would think they would want
people to know that because that's us
you know owning property taking down the
patriarchy why don't they teach that
stuff
yeah it's because it you know nothing
that goes against The Narrative of the
woman is victimized innocent is allowed
to be
taught I think you know why like is it
the professors is it like yes principles
or like like I'm just trying to figure
out like who's behind this stuff you
know what I mean
yeah
um something remarkable happened in the
late 60s early 70s
um as feminists invaded Academia
and in a very you know remarkably short
time with very little pushback
they established women's studies now
called you know gender studies programs
in the universities and they established
them in you know pretty well every
single institution of higher education
all across North America and I mean
obviously in Britain and probably
elsewhere in in the western world as
well certainly in Australia New Zealand
and
um and then and then that ideology that
that they brought into women's studies
spread into every single other
discipline first it was mainly in the
humanities then it went into the social
sciences they colonized every single
discipline they're now finally taking
over the Natural Sciences
um you know physics astrophysics they're
all trying to hire women
over physics like how do you put a
gendered spin on physics well they they
managed to do so uh that there are I've
read papers about feminist glaciology
I've read you know all sorts of crazy
feminist spins but it isn't so much that
the like in the Natural Sciences it's
not so much or certainly biology is
being taken over big time you know ideas
about gender and whether gender is
socially constructed or whether it has a
bedrock in nature that obviously is a
very important discipline for for
feminism and all radical gender theories
um but in in a in a discipline like
astrophysics as I understand it it's not
so much that the actual science that's
being done is being changed but what is
happening is that they're bringing in
ideologues to occupy positions who
essentially occupy a separate tier of
Academia and what they do is they go
around giving talks about how
um
stem programs have got to become more
diverse they have to include more women
more people of color
Etc more genderqueer peoples and those
people
um you know they monitor the climate uh
you know not the actual climate but the
the atmosphere in those departments they
do surveys about what needs to be done
to make women's lives easier in those
disciplines they they write reports
about how more needs to be done for
these oppressed minority groups
um you know they that that's what they
do that becomes their career so you have
this whole orientation within those
disciplines to promote diversity and how
you know how it was allowed to be done
I mean that's it's a huge question I I
mean at there's an interesting book
called
um the the closing of the American Mind
by Alan Bloom which was published I
think in 1987 or thereabouts and he's
really talking in that book about that
this takeover of of the University by
social justice and he talks about his
experience in the 1960s
and
his argument is really that academics
lost faith in their disciplines they
they they just they lost faith in the
relevance of
truth seeking
and curiosity driven research
and they
they were ripe to be convinced that
becoming a warrior For A Cause was more
important than actually investigating
16th century French poetry let's say
yeah uh and and so you know if you if
you ask somebody who who teaches at a
university and and all of those people
they have this longing for relevance I
think you know to feel that they're
doing something really important so if
you ask somebody what they're doing and
they say I'm changing the world you know
I'm I'm making the world safer for women
I'm going to model woman power for the
next generation of girls or I'm making
it possible for uh black women to
believe that they can be astrophysicists
that sounds a lot better than just you
know I'm researching this one very
narrow
you know this specialty Topic in a
particular field and I think it's mean
too to be honest I like have friends
that went into like male dominated
fields and a lot of them hate it like
they're pushed there's these free
scholarships through these free grants
yes they all say women come into
engineering come into all this and like
I have a friend she spent 300K on an
engineering like master or something
graduated she's like I hate this I don't
even like it like I don't even think
it's like it's funny because their their
idea of what we should do I don't even
think is like nice to women because it's
like trying to make us into something
we're not like if you're naturally
interested in something you're gonna
find it anyway
exactly you know and that and that was
the thing that
um some disciplines never had a problem
attracting women
um women were always interested in
English literature uh because that's the
kind of thing that women tend to like
and so there was never an issue of
trying to get more women into English
literature but in the disciplines that
men tend to like because they're really
focused on numbers and things rather
than on people women tend to be more
interested in people related disciplines
and men tend to be interested in you
know the hard number kind of disciplines
uh yeah um to entice women into those
areas by telling them that in some way
they are striking a blow for all women
by entering a field that that is you
know has an underrepresentation of women
it doesn't do any favors to the woman
and I actually I think it makes
everything worse in the sense that if
you get hired on an equity ticket it's
as a woman or as a racial minority
whatever it happens to be but I'm
especially interested in the gender
issue you get hired on an equity ticket
you know it and everybody else knows it
too and even now like they still have a
lot of positions that they're
advertising for women only imagine
applying for a job that's for women only
you've had your special scholarship
you've been you know promoted because
you're a woman and now you're you you
compete for a job that excludes men from
the competition uh there's something
humiliating about that there's some
recognition there that women can't
compete just on a open playing field so
and then you get hired into that
position
and I think there's already an
undercurrent of uneasiness and
resentment and suspicion you know on
both sides and the woman who has that
feeling that maybe she's not quite as
good or she's there or only because she
was hired under this special decisions
then she starts to feel
uncomfortable and if she doesn't do that
well
instead of perhaps recognizing that she
really shouldn't be there what she's
going to do is think this is because of
sexism I've been made to feel I don't
belong here because there's still this
invisible but somehow palpable culture
of resentment against me because I'm a
woman
then that turns into all sorts of other
problems she ends up accusing one or
more of her colleagues of sexual
harassment she's over alert to anything
that might seem to be a criticism of her
as a woman I mean it is a recipe for
dysfunction and for allegations against
men and men I mean it's you we can say
yeah it's hard on a woman but she's
never going to be fired
right the man is the one who then ends
up being accused of something and he
loses his job and he was the brilliant
man I just did a piece actually I just
wrote a piece um in on my substack
newsletter about a
brilliant
astrophysicist astronomer actually I
think and a brilliant man Jeff Marcy and
he was he was drummed out of his
position like he was in the running for
a Nobel prize for the kinds of
contributions he was making to his field
he was drummed out
over extremely vague
accusations of sexual impropriety and
we're not talking about sex with
students we're talking about one woman
who said he gave her a neck massage
when he was driving her home because she
was telling him about something that she
was tense about so he started giving her
a neck massage and she got out of the
car at that point and she felt
uncomfortable about it and some of these
checks don't talk about what they were
doing too exactly it's like some of you
will be half naked and then men will hit
on you and you're like why did they hit
on me and I'm just like well it's a bit
I'm not saying like the student
Professor thing like I I get it but it's
like some of you guys you look like
hookers at work and then you're you're
mad when they treat you like a hooker at
work like I don't know what you expected
to happen
yeah the whole sexual harassment
industry which started really going in
the 1990s and has been expanding ever
since it it's
it's
yeah full of problems in in exactly the
way that you just put your finger on but
and and the the issue at universities is
really complicated because
um I mean when I started University
there were a number of professors at the
University of British Columbia where I
attended who were married and they had
met as you know Prof in Professor
student relationships we're not talking
about an older Professor with an 18 year
old girl but we're talking about
graduate students often you know they're
in their mid-20s late 20s the poor guy
must have just been preyed upon by the
women you know what I mean what about
the guy he was praying well I yeah I've
I've talked to a lot of male professors
who say that it's not at all uncommon
for young women to be really sexually
provocative because and the fact is
young women are attracted to older men
and even you know University professors
maybe they're not the hunkiest sort of
guys but they are men with knowledge
and that is itself very very attractive
to certain kinds of younger women so
there's all sorts of romantic and sexual
tension between those constituents and
in some cases what's wrong with it
everyone says oh there's a power
differential well yeah in a way but
actually not really if anything the
woman has the power she has the power to
accuse
and have you ever seen like the have you
ever seen the power like a super hot
chick just has on men like what they
just walk into a room they'll get
whatever they want it's like they're
they're enticed like they act like
there's no power in Beauty
like yes what about what about the
beauty palette but they just act like it
it doesn't exist
there's no power being extremely
beautiful
well that's that's uh you know that that
is it like the the feminist worldview is
always like they they they look with
eagle eyes at all the forms of advantage
that they think men have and men's
particular types of power and men do
have particular types of power but but
they never recognize the power that
women have exactly as you say the power
of beauty other types of power too the
power to you know Express distress at
something and to have men act on it I
had a friend telling me about once how
he was in a workspace
and
he and his colleagues they were all
working and they heard this woman
screaming outside
and they all just you know without
thinking like just tore outside to try
to help whoever whatever you know and it
was clearly a woman screaming out I mean
the entire history of the feminist
movement has been the history of women
expressing distress essentially
screaming about things that they felt
were wrong in their society and Men
responding and saying what can we do
about it that is a very particular form
of female power the feminists never
recognized there's the power to accuse
we're now in that era when any woman can
accuse any man
and she is listened to even if the
accusation is quite outlandish and even
if the man absolutely denies it's still
likely that his at least his reputation
is going to be harmed if not you know
his entire like professional life
uh even his Liberty if if he ends up
being jailed as a result of her
accusation so so those particular types
of power are incredible not to mention
of course the power to shame men which
feminists and women in general have have
uh have activated over the years so so
yeah there's you know there's all those
issues around the promotion of women in
universities and like and how it
actually happened I don't know I mean
it's just it was a an uh that ideology
just proved so attractive that now
there are no universities that aren't
dominated by
feminist ideals and
feminist Frameworks of knowledge and it
means that like the whole field of
social science has been corrupted it
means that you know feminists can cite
all sorts of studies about domestic
violence about sexual harassment about
rape and none of those studies can be
trusted
they're all corrupted because they are
agenda driven
and I've looked into a few you know
outrageous claims and it turns out that
like none of the studies
um on which those claims are based are
actually
viable they're they're not real studies
you know that terrible how do you tell
the difference between like a because
this has happened to me before where
someone will like quote a study and this
is why sometimes I just like I don't
need to study to tell me what I see in
front of my eyes do you know what I mean
exactly and they'll give me like this
one debate I did this guy was like oh
you're misleading people because here's
the study that say like women prefer to
sleep with the husband that does the
chores I'm like do they really yes yeah
yeah and I'm like look it I I don't need
a PhD and stupid to tell me that like
like that every woman I know whose
husband does everything to make her
happy hates her husband for whatever
reason I don't like I I just don't but
it's tough because you you get into
debates with these people and it's hard
because they'll just bring up these
studies that you know like deep down or
not true but you don't know how to like
disprove that like these are clearly
ideological studies yes exactly and that
that is the huge problem like there is
now like a literal Army of feminist
scholars in every single discipline they
they took over journals they cite one
another's research
uh you can read a feminist paper and it
will often have a a citation for nearly
every single sentence so it looks as if
why I mean this is you know it's rock
solid it seems but if you actually look
into you know you go to the link and you
read the study but like who has the time
to do that but if you do you often find
that the studies are flawed in various
ways now I would you know there is no
easy answer to that like it's that is
this is what we're left with after 40
Years of agenda driven ideologically
framed research in the universities is
that people can cite studies to
defend indefensible positions and it's
very difficult to respond there is um a
great book by a woman named Christina
Hoff Summers and it's called who stole
feminism it was published quite a while
ago now like 1989 maybe you're the early
90s I can't remember number
um maybe late 90s and she actually goes
through a lot of the
fundamental feminist studies and and she
did the research and she shows how they
are flawed and you know the the and they
can be flawed in all sorts of ways by
having a you know a sample size that's
that's way too small by actually
ignoring the responses of
um perhaps mail survey recipients if
it's a case where they're trying to
prove that women not you know experience
a certain amount of sexual assault and
they don't count the male responses
um uh I mean there's just all sorts of
they ask
um leading questions or perhaps the
people that they surveyed are people who
volunteered for the survey meaning that
like you you know you advertising I'm
doing a study on victims of domestic
violence and so all sorts of victims of
domestic violence come forward because
they're interested in that study you
know so it's it's it's totally skewed
right from the beginning but the the sad
fact is that ultimately
yeah you know it's very it's like so
time consuming just recently there was a
a campaign in my city
sponsored by the YWCA
this made me so annoyed uh sponsored by
the YWCA young women's Christian
Association which is a you know taxpayer
uh funded organization gets millions of
dollars from the government every year
it was sponsoring a campaign to raise
awareness of the number of women who
allegedly have traumatic brain injury
as a result of domestic violence
it was being sponsored by a guy named
Trevor Linden who was a famous hockey
player he played for the Vancouver
Canucks he was actually the Canucks
captain and these well-known in
Vancouver probably all across North
America for hockey fans and he was
um talking it up and saying how shocked
he had been to learn of the numbers of
girls and women who experience
concussion this
so-called study claimed that
hundreds of thousands of girls and women
in Canada every year experience a
concussion from domestic violence it
said that for every hockey player every
professional hockey player who has a
concussion 7 000 girls and women get
them from domestic violence so people
sent me this and said like there's no
way this is true they claimed that up to
92 percent of the hundreds of thousands
of women who experienced domestic
violence every year
up to 92 percent of them have
concussions as a result and nobody knows
you know and we need to raise awareness
and we need to get more funding so they
can be you know properly treated and and
people sent me this study thing like
there's no way there's no way this can
be true everybody would know at least
one girl and probably you know a dozen
who had experienced a concussion so I
actually looked into it and it's just
all it's not true none of it it's based
on two major it had two major links
one of them was a statistics Canada
study of intimate partner violence huge
survey
and it found that over four out of ten
girls and women in their lifetimes will
experience intimate partner violence
and that of those four out of ten not up
to 92 percent of them will have a
concussion so that means three out of
ten women and girls in Canada
are going to have a concussion
like really and so I okay I looked at
how do they how do they Define violence
guess what they call violence
almost anything they call violence
psychological violence so if somebody
calls you names in your relationship
that's violence if somebody is jealous
and controlling in the relationship
that's violence if they throw something
at you the whole thing these ladies will
be like oh I can't go to the club at 2
A.M he's coerced yes controlling me I'm
like what the they just make it I
mean words that like don't mean anything
and you don't yeah they don't I know
it's so so the violence I mean some of
this was abuse yes it's not nice to be
called names I suppose but um and that
can be very hurtful I wouldn't recommend
it but it's not going to cause a
concussion so they they you know they
you didn't call him any names like come
that's my question it's like you guys
get into these fights and you're just
innocent you just you can't fight with
someone unless you fight back you know
what I like you're just sitting there
minding your business and the men just
say I'm gonna be an abuser today okay
like I'm sure it happens but three and
ten really yeah and it's just ridiculous
and actually put a pin in that in that
point about about what the woman has
done because I want to come back to that
but okay so so this the whole survey is
useless in terms of
um you know talking about concussions
because it defined violence so
incredibly elastically that it would
include anything even things that you
know couldn't possibly cause a
concussion obviously and um but and then
there was one other where they got the
92 percent number from that is even more
interesting and sort of frightening the
other study was a study an American
study of 95 black women who had
experienced severe violence it found
that including violence in childhood
right up until their adult lives
it found that one-third of those had
experienced traumatic brain injury from
repeated violence and specifically they
talked about the types of violence that
caused traumatic brain injury which are
choking until you you black out and
blows to the Head
so but that still didn't explain the 92
percent that study referred to another
study which I then went and read and get
this in that study they looked at
women who had traumatic brain injury and
found that 92 percent of those had
received the brain injury from violence
so see they flipped it around it so that
they took a sample small sample of women
with concussion and found that 92
percent of those had got it from the
domestic violence then they flipped it
around and said that all victims of
intimate partner violence even if that's
just someone throwing a cookie at you
that all the up to up to 92 percent of
those would experience concussion like
it doesn't it doesn't make any sense and
the thing is that
the people making those claims they're
either so stupid that they didn't read
the studies properly
or they're being deliberately
dishonest
and either way I find it appalling like
I felt I mean then that concussion
campaign it was broadcast all over like
in every major paper in in my city and
at the national level like the YWCA
should have to disavow that campaign
they should have to come forward and say
that all the numbers that they use were
false Trevor Linden should stand up and
disavow the campaign and say he's sorry
that he promoted a lie because those
lies are really serious those lies mean
that people are inclined to believe that
all men are violent that means that
every time a man is accused of beating
his wife people are going to say hey I
remember that campaign that said that
hundreds of thousands of girls and women
every year suffer concussion from
domestic violence so that bastard is
probably guilty he should be locked up
because I'm sure he did beat his wife
and and of course it misinforms women
about the reality of of men Because the
actual fact is that
serious domestic violence is a
relatively rare phenomenon it is not
hundreds of thousands of women and girls
and to come back to your point
serious studies of the phenomenon have
found that women participate in hitting
punching kicking Etc both at low levels
and at higher levels of intensity
at
pretty much gender parity they they
participate in it in fact some studies
find that that women tend to initiate
the violence more than men do and that
makes sense to me yeah that's what I
found out too just doing the show
because I've had like 100 I've had like
probably a thousand chicks in and out of
here and I just realized all these
crying about abuse none of them
were abused because they all hit for
every time I would like dig into it and
be like what happened sorry sorry for my
language but it's like it's like I just
get irritated they never tell the other
side of the story where it's like you're
coming on my podcast making your
ex-boyfriend who everyone knows
everyone's gonna think he's an abuser
now which because you know if you're in
a public relationship with him when you
didn't talk about you hit him first like
these feminists they want to be equal so
be equal take the hit like you know what
I mean be equal I know well it and and
you know and I was reading this this one
researcher he's a sociologist he looks
at he looked at 200 studies of intimate
partner violence which did find exactly
what you're saying that the women
participate equally and often more so
that they're the ones who initiate the
violence that like that makes sense to
me in the sense that we as women like I
was never told not to be violent I my
parents never
said you know you should never hit you
know anyone that you're involved in I
mean I I was a pretty I'm pretty girly
girl I
wasn't uh inclined to be very violent
but um you know it like the the
implication is that there are no natural
tendencies in girls that need to be
curbed it's always boys boys are taught
that right from from day one and what
this sociologist Murray Strauss
the point he was making was if feminists
were really serious about
um making homes safer for women and and
reducing the number of women who do
suffer from serious violence because of
course men are stronger than women so
more women end up being seriously
injured and even killed as a result of
intimate partner violence although it is
not insignificant like men account for
about one-third of serious injuries
because if you've got a big pot of
boiling water or you grab a knife then
that kind of equalizes the gender power
imbalance so so men account for about
one-third of those who are seriously
injured and about one-third of those who
are killed by their intimate Partners so
it's not insignificant men are killed
more than or women are men are killed
more than women
oh yes definitely I'm talking just about
I didn't know that
no no well men no men men account for
about one-third of of uh deaths from
intimate partner violence okay so it's
about
um yeah about three to one is the the
ratio of women who are killed by their
intimate partners and and men but but
men generally are the victims of
homicide much more often they're like
about 80 percent of 80 or 85 percent of
homicide victims but the point Murray
Strauss was making was the feminist
really cared about reducing women's
um
vulnerability to domestic violence like
the primary factor the primary indicator
of whether a woman is going to be
the victim of domestic violence is
whether she herself is violent
wow so one of the first things you would
say to women you know as a general
campaign was don't hit your partner
if you never hit your partner your
likelihood of being hit drops
dramatically but because feminists
aren't really interested they're not
interested in stopping domestic violence
they didn't need it they need it for
their funding they need it for their
ideology they need it for their
worldview which posits that men are
violent and women are victims so they
don't want to say that I'm just to the
point
I'm sorry I just believe no women
anymore like it's I've just interviewed
like hundreds like hundreds and hundreds
of hard drives and it's like every
accusation there's never a police report
they never talk and like whenever I
break down the story it's usually her
fault and I'm like what what world are
we living in where we can just throw
these baseless accusations I'm like I
believe nobody I believe nobody
well I mean I think a skeptical
um sort of stance is is a good one you
know one should believe evidence like
yeah
um again there's two things there oh she
said she said I I was abused I had an
abusive partner and I was like all right
lady tell me about this abuse you
brought it up so let's what happened
lady I didn't say I was nicer than that
but you know and then she tells me that
he asked her to leave she refused to
leave his house
so now lady you're trespassing all right
this is he says leave you will not leave
and he pushes her outside and she falls
what
is this abuse
yeah get out of the house like what are
you doing in the house
yeah
yeah I know I mean yeah and that's it
you know that when I was looking at that
statscan survey they have all these
different categories of types of
violence that the survey you know uh
respondents were asked about and like
one of them was were you ever shoved and
I was thinking like there's so you know
there's such a variety of what that
could be like yeah it could be kind of
violent for sure
um or it could be that the woman is
harassing her man you know screaming at
him getting in his face yelling at him
telling him he's no good Etc and he
finally like maybe you know she's
blocking the doorway so he can't even
get out of the room and so he shoves her
out of the way to you know and then that
counts as a man being violent to the
woman but the whole context of how it
came about is never counted in in that
survey so yeah it's it's always so so
complicated and
yeah I mean I I
like I just I feel like the the entire
believe woman
climate that we live in where every time
a woman makes an accusation everybody
you know they get their voices get
hushed and the woman all of a sudden has
all this Authority I think it's so
damaging not only for men obviously but
it's damaging for women too like it's
like we don't hold women to a high moral
standard and we encourage
the worst in women we encourage you know
their narcissism I want a counter
movement called believe no women
remember Annie
I just like believe no women just I just
think
this is my new campaign
I'm kid I'm half kidding you know what I
mean but but yeah it's just like I don't
understand why we have this like default
like we all
we are the worst versions of ourselves
in a breakup like you cannot tell like
most chicks married single whatever you
probably have done something you're not
proud of during a breakup at some point
in your life we're human but now we have
the government legally allowing you it's
like if we illegally if we got men as
angry as possible and legally said
here's a gun you can kill the man you
hate the most on the planet like when
they're in the middle of a fight right
I bet some guys would do it I feel like
that's what they're doing to women it's
like what were the worst I mean because
come on we can just be spiteful when
we're the worst versions of ourselves
they legally give us a gun it's like
yeah why would you why would you do that
I know I know it is really incredible
actually
um I A friend of mine uh that that is
his metaphor actually for what
what feminism in in accordance we're in
line with the state has done to male
female relations it's it's essentially
given Every Woman a loaded gun that she
can keep in her bedside table like
metaphorically speaking although
sometimes even physically speaking and
uh and every every man
knows that it's there and every woman
knows that it's there at least anybody
who's been paying attention to gender
politics over the last 30 years and how
can you have a healthy relationship
when you know that the woman can use
that gun with impunity she can accuse
her man of whatever and in Canada
certainly in parts of the United States
and other English-speaking countries we
have mandatory charging policies where
if the woman makes an accusation if she
says you know he hit me Etc even if
there's no evidence and that man denies
it the police have to charge the man
and that's you know that's the beginning
of the end for that guy and depending on
how far the woman wants to go and how
she wants to use that accusation that
can be it if they have children together
she can deny him the right to see his
children he can spend years fighting
just to get visitation rights let alone
the right to actually parent his
children as he wants to I mean it's it's
it's yeah it's mind-boggling when you
when you look into how the feminist
worldview has translated into just
horrific police policies can you so
I understand a bit about family court so
like I know in family court at least in
the UK they've switched it to like a
balance of probabilities
um which means essentially it's like
more likely than not likely so it's not
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
um right and then I know they've like
expanded the definition of like abuse
rape sexual assault so like we don't
really know what any of those words mean
anymore but I don't know as much about
like Criminal Court is Criminal Court
more fair than family court
well criminal court is a little better
and it still has you know beyond A
Reasonable Doubt but
um there's all sorts of problems with it
as well I'm not an expert here so um you
know I can't go into a lot of detail but
from everything I've read
what feminists have done is to chip away
at all of the legal avenues that a man
can use to defend himself in a court of
law against a charge of sexual assault
of course it's sexual assault now which
you know can has a very elastic
definition as well
um but uh
you know the the man is not able for
example to use anything about the
woman's sexual history as his defense so
it means that
much about their previous relationship
can be hidden from the jury and so it's
very difficult for him to explain you
know how he came to the point where he
may have done a certain thing that's
that seems
um you know unjustified in Canada for
example
um there was a famous trial by uh of a
man named Gian gomeshi who was a um he
was a CBC media darling he uh he worked
for the public broadcaster and did
interviews and everybody loved him all
of a sudden his life fell apart a bunch
of women came forward and accused him of
sexual assault it seemed like it was a
slam dunk case there was a bunch of a
chorus of voices saying he'd done
terrible things
and uh ended up going to trial three
women accusing him it turned out that
everything in the in their accusations
was a lie they had conspired together to
construct the accusations against him
they had there were text messages
between the three of them as they got
their stories straight they were all
cases of essentially jilted lovers who
were angry that he hadn't treated them
very well
they were all interested in getting back
with him uh the the
um the thing that saved him was that he
had kept all of his emails and and all
of his text messages from these women
and so they were asked on the witness
stand whether uh you know they'd ever
contacted him after the alleged assault
and they said oh no of course not it was
so painful I couldn't bear to even you
know contemplate talking to him then the
evidence would come forward that hey
actually a year later this particular
complainant sent a picture of herself in
a bikini to the accused uh and you know
it was clearly interested in
reigniting the relationship another one
had sent after a weekend in on which he
had allegedly raped her she sent him the
following day uh a bouquet of flowers
and said I love your hands all sorts of
evidence that
what had happened what they claimed had
happened hadn't happened anything like
that
so that's how he proved his innocence
they lied on the stand and they didn't
realize he would still have all of this
evidence because these accusations came
years after the alleged assaults
so now in Canada there's been an attempt
and in fact it's been successful
to make it that text and email evidence
cannot be introduced
into the man's defense unless it's
cleared with the prosecution and the
judge now what that means is they're
claiming that this is to protect the
woman's privacy because a lot of these
personal exchanges you know their
confidential information private
information
so now the defense will have to bring
forward all the evidence that they have
and they'll have to present it to the
prosecutor and the judge that means the
prosecutor will know what the defense
has in its Arsenal the prosecutor will
communicate that to the accusers or
accuser and she will be able to con
construct her story around the knowledge
of what emails and text messages he has
that's just one of the ways that
feminist activists are chipping away at
the man's ability to make a full defense
against a claim of sexual assault
and you know I it that is just
remarkable and yet that is being allowed
to pass so the whole idea of the
presumption of innocence
it's still there in Criminal Court more
than it is in family court and family
court basically you know you can make
any kind of accusation and it doesn't
have to be proved at all you can just
say he threatened me or even I fear for
the safety of my children and that that
will may be enough to convince a judge
and of course most judges they're
terrified of being too lenient and then
having something happen to that woman
and then everyone will accuse him of
endangering her so judges are very
concerned to side with the woman in the
vast majority of cases but in the
criminal court too you can see how the
man's ability to defend himself is being
weakened
so when it comes to you mentioned that
feminists basically rewrite history
or they don't talk about like historical
women that have been influential in
history and act like we were oppressed
can you tell me a bit more about how
feminists basically rewrite history
well I mean everything is filtered
through through the feminist lens and
[Music]
um
yeah uh it
feminists are not really interested in
objectively portraying uh the situation
of women historically or the situation
of women you know in the present day
they're they're uh they're interested in
promoting their agenda and I can
understand like if you believe that
um horrific abuses are occurring every
day all around us and have occurred
throughout history then it seems a
fairly small thing to bend the facts to
fit your narrative yeah and um they'll
all say all the women were just being
beaten and abused and they just couldn't
get divorced and that's why they were
married
that's like the whole
like whenever I bring up that women were
married 100 years ago like 85 percent of
women were married
or people they they all say that it's
because
of like the women just like getting
beaten and they're not able to leave and
their husbands were just raping them are
you saying that's not true
well you know it's we we don't like
there are meant some things we really
don't know about the lives of ordinary
women in in the 19th century uh you know
our our Avenues to really fully
understanding individual women's lives
are actually quite limited but when you
read
um Diaries of women from the time uh you
get quite a different picture when you
read the journalism that women wrote in
those days I mean women you know it's
this is I know you made this point uh I
think on the uh the Pierce Morgan uh uh
interview whatever that was uh by the
way I wanted to say I thought you did a
fantastic job thank you and that like I
I was interviewed him by him once years
ago when he was on um Good Morning
Britain and I I hate those situations
like you have such limited time to say
anything and they sort of you know they
put you on the spot and then and then
you know someone and then a feminist
like Cuts you off and you know makes
some dismissive comment but I I thought
you handled it well and I also I just I
like your
like your whole demeanor was so
different from the The Other Woman Ava
or whatever her name is that uh you know
she was so just so unpleasant and yeah
yeah but I'm just so tired of hearing
about how we couldn't do anything and
there weren't yeah influential women I'm
like they're absolutely were there were
yeah that's it I know that that's and
that's the that's what's so
uh is you know it's so fascinating like
it's this idea that uh you know up until
about 1975 women were just trapped in
their homes they they were voiceless
they were utterly powerless they
couldn't affect their society and you
know that was the thing when I turned my
uh my thesis into a book
um
like I I couldn't write it as a a
feminist book anymore really because it
was impossible to ignore
the power that those women had like one
of the women that I
um wrote about I still think she's a
wonderful person she was born in 1864
and uh so she you know she was born half
a century before women had the right to
vote but she didn't see herself as
oppressed at all and she wasn't you know
she went to and she was and she was not
wealthy she did not inherit money she
wasn't in uh you know
exceptional circumstances she grew up in
a lower middle class small town in
Ontario
and she went to the Brantford Collegiate
which was a you know okay
post-secondary uh Institute and
she became a journalist at a very young
age she started to write for the Globe
newspaper which became the Globe and
Mail that still exists today she wrote
for the Washington Post which of course
is still it's a major leftist paper now
and she lived in Washington for a time
she wrote social commentary she wrote
book reviews she wrote theater reviews
like she did all sorts of things she was
basically given a free hand she was in
her early twenties at the time she was
intelligent she was Lively she attended
feminist conventions with a skeptical
eye like she was a sort of a moderate
feminist her point was that women would
need to know a heck of a lot more about
world affairs and basic things like
economics and you know the political
system than they did at present if they
were going to ever be responsible voters
and so that was the point she made you
know she she thought she would be a
pretty good voter but she had some
skepticism about whether her most of her
fellow women would be but she had no
sense that you know that like there were
no Avenues of endeavor that were close
to her and this is we're talking about
the 1880s she actually said that it was
a golden age for Girls full of
opportunities she she worked as a
teacher
she had a friend who became a professor
of medicine uh she had another friend
who became a doctor uh you know like all
of those professions were opening to
women and uh yeah the idea that
um that that women were struggling and
oppressed yeah some women had a terrible
time poor women had a terrible time and
so did poor men
uh and you know and and it the fact that
the feminist movement is utterly
incapable of recognizing that yeah if
you're going to talk about the
disabilities and difficulties of of a
group of people's lives
you can only do it responsibly if you
compare it to other people's lives in
this case to men's lives and men's lives
were very very difficult many men of
course in in the 19th century didn't
have the right to vote either and that
fact alone to me is like the fact that I
didn't know that when I was writing my
PhD dissertation
including on the suffrage movement I had
no idea and nobody told me and none of
the sources talked about the fact that
many men were barred from voting there
were property and income qualifications
in place
throughout the English-speaking world
and no feminist ever cared about those
and it puts the whole issue into an
entirely different light
yeah you know and and
they don't do
oh sorry oh no I say go have gone
yeah and and the other thing is that
like feminists don't do uh they don't do
justice to the anti-feminist position
which was complex and and interesting
um
one of the questions that was often
asked at the time to women who were
arguing they should have the right to
vote at the federal level and by the way
like women all well at least for a long
time
could vote at like the municipal level
they could vote on school boards you
know things like that
um in the United States various states
did Grant voting rights at the state
level to women it was just at the
federal level that the mistake Yeah Yeah
well yeah I mean you know and this is
the question and you know the the there
are all sorts of issues that have to do
with with with the vote why were so many
women
either not interested or quite
strenuously opposed I mean for one thing
they they felt that most of the women
who were active in support of woman
suffrage most of them were
had an anti-mail agenda and so they were
concerned that
those women would drive politics and
social ideas that would drive a wedge
between men and women
and hey guess what that's exactly what
happened
they lied about men they were involved
in that cause partly or even maybe
primarily because they were angry about
men
um men do have different
responsibilities in a in their societies
that
make an argument for why perhaps they
should also have certain privileges
certain political Privileges and this
was something that was asked many of the
feminist advocates for the vote uh they
would say you know
the ballot is in some ways a substitute
bullet
in the sense that politics is war
by another means if you are a voter that
means you are taking responsibility for
the direction of your country if for
some reason the as a result of political
decisions that the voters have made if
it results in Civil War if it results in
a war with another country
male voters are the ones who are going
to have to shoulder that horrific burden
they're the ones who are going to have
to step forward and potentially
sacrifice their lives to
protect their countries so what do you
say to the women that say well we
haven't had a war in 50 years
well there's a war going on right now in
in Ukraine and it's not clear that the
whole world won't be drawn into that in
one way or another it certainly seems as
if uh the United States is itching to
turn that war into a much larger
conflagration and we saw what happened
you know all the women or many of the
women left Ukraine and the men are
forced to stay behind and fight
so you can see a very Stark difference
there in terms of the roles and
responsibilities of men and women now
nobody's necessarily saying that women
should be soldiers I think that would
actually be
pretty disastrous in all sorts of ways
so but you know what about
that distinction like how do you
how do you justify claiming that you
care about equality when most feminists
do not want women to have to register
for the draft and I I don't think they
should either like I don't think the
society is even prepared to see women
women's bodies coming home in body bags
the society's not prepared to see women
with their arms
amputated as a result of their
involvement in battle like you know the
the the differences in how we look upon
men's and women's bodies the different
ways we value men and women are so Stark
it's a lie to pretend that those
differences don't exist and I was just
reading a couple days ago about the the
sinking of the Titanic
and how
you know that was 1912. so it's right
during the time when the whole
um suffrage argument was going on and
there was again a really Stark
illustration of the different ways that
men and women relate to public
sacrifice and the different ways that
men and women's lives are valued uh when
that ship went down about 75 percent of
women survived it would have been much
higher if there hadn't been women in the
lower uh decks in the steerage
passenger area
97 of first class and something like 86
percent of second class
um
cabinet passengers
women survived and and and only about 20
percent of men survived so that was the
difference and you know the the crew
stood with
with pistols loaded to make sure that
women and children got onto the
lifeboats before men and you read the
stories about men you know kissing their
wives goodbye and knowing that they were
never going to see them again and in
uh preparing for their deaths
with dignity
and uh you know and afterwards people
did actually talk about these issues
like in some some anti-feminist said
well feminists so what do you want do
you want equality
or do you want to survive when the ship
goes down well you know
that was a turning point for me when I
realized like you can't have equality
like the whole basis of equality men and
women can't be equal because we can't do
what they can do
I'm like there's no way like that we can
never get what they're hoping for
like especially I found out I did
research after the Pierce Morgan
interview if you include like far and
you might know this like you've done so
much research but like when you include
like farming when you include like
Truckers when you include all the
infrastructure of society it's 45
percent of men have infrastructure jobs
and that doesn't even include like
there's like one or two I can't remember
what it was there's one in two
industries where it was kind of like do
we need um do we not we'll just say no
like I didn't include like store owners
you know like stuff like that right but
argue also includes the infrastructure
so and only seven percent of women do
and let's just be honest like do we need
those like two percent of women in the
police department
like do we really do we really need them
and that's what I realized I was like
they pay 72 percent of the taxes
so it's like they're paying all the
taxes they're running Society like why
aren't we fighting for it to actually be
equal
yeah
you don't hear a lot of feminists
clamoring to uh you know to to have
equal representation and Sewer working
and you know Roofing and Construction
jobs and the dangerous dirty smelly
horrible uh danger you know really I
mean 97 of workplace fatalities are
borne by by men you know do women want
that to be 50 female and even the jobs
they want like the CEO positions my dad
was a CEO of like 250 people roughly
and I'm like women don't want to work as
much as he did like he would go to India
for two weeks at a time he would go to
the office at like three in the morning
to talk to the people because he had um
software developers in India and so he
would like work in the middle then I
like I'm like I I'm I'm a pretty hard
worker but I I cannot work like my dad
did and it's like these feminists they
don't
they just want like to look cool I feel
like it's just for Instagram sometimes
like they just want to look cool in
these jobs look pretty and like they
don't like they don't want to like what
percent of feminists want to work 80
hours a week yeah I know yeah I don't
want to work 80 hours no I know and that
that's that's what I find so
hypocritical is that it's yeah it's like
they want the job they they want the job
uh they want that idea of having that
job but they don't actually want to do
what's necessary to have the job and and
then if they do get the job often
through some sort of process of being
selected because they're women because a
lot of law firms want to have a woman on
in The Firm or a couple of women and it
was even law in in California for a
while that every every corporate board
had to have a woman on it otherwise it
would be find some very large sum so you
know for a while there I think there
were there were CEOs going around you
know get me a woman I need a woman on
this board uh so so that idea of of some
sort of forced representation seems to
be very very uh attractive to women but
then once they get into those positions
they start complaining about how
difficult it is and then they want
things to change for them I want to be
in a man's world but when they're
treated like a man they go to HR it's
like if women left the workforce
tomorrow we would have no HR because
women are just like like we just whine
it's like I when I start hearing about
these HR I used to sell um I used to
work in like Plumbing Tech so I would go
to like a plumber's like training
centers and we would
um like show them how to use Plumbing
products like I didn't know anything
about it I was just selling the stuff
you know what I mean and but it was an
all-male environment like I think
there's maybe one or two women in the
whole like Plumbing training whatever
and they're very masculine women like
they're they're they might have like
Butch you know what I mean and
I I just couldn't believe how those men
talk to each other they were so mean
they would just bully the hell out of
each other like like and I'm and I'm
thinking like that's a man's world but
if this happened to any woman if women
were bullied like that they would be in
HR the next day
whining suing crying sexism when I'm
like that is the mean I forgot what they
were saying to this one guy but it was I
felt so bad for him that's just how guys
don't be brutal yeah yeah
but they don't I know and that you know
that's like the story of what has
happened to so many workplaces over the
last 40 years is that women demanded
access and then once they got in there
they realized they didn't like the
climate that was there and so then they
started complaining they didn't like
that one guy had a girly calendar up in
his office cubicle you know so they said
that was sexual harassment he had to
take it down they didn't like it the men
made certain types of jokes and so you
know they complained about it and and
jokes from men why would you guys do men
love that yeah I know I mean and so
it is really incredible it's like you
know there used to be this idea that
there were separate spheres the women
sort of ran the home and men had their
workspaces but gradually most men's
workspaces have been feminized and yeah
it's just it's so unfair and and
hypocritical
what about so what like men's like what
policy changes would you like to see
when it comes to like advocating for
men's rights
well
um yeah I guess
on the most basic level I would like I
would like it to become impossible for I
mean this isn't a policy change per se
but I would just like it to become
impossible for women to express hatred
against men or at least I would like it
that it would become Unthinkable that
women who
lie about men who lie using statistics
or who openly Express their hatred
against men
would be laughed out of the room
because I find that so
unforgivable there are you know just
even to confine it to Academia
there are so many women if you you uh
look on their Twitter feeds for example
or look at the Articles they write
there's a professor named Susanna
Walters at South
no Northeastern University I think
who um
she wrote a whole article in the
Washington Post called why can't we hate
men with a big picture of Harvey
Weinstein on the front and you know you
think is this going to be a is this a is
it going to be satirical in some way is
there going to be a Twist at the end
where she says no actually I don't hate
all men that would be ridiculous no it
is a crude simplistic statement about
why it is morally Justified to hate men
and why women are morally Superior yeah
yeah it's real yeah it's incredible that
I think it was back in 2017.
and it's a horrible article she she
basically says to men you deserve to be
hated all of you but if you want us to
not hate you for all time here's what
you have to do you have to step away
from the power you have to never take
powerful positions you have to vote for
feminist women you know you have to do
this and that and then maybe we won't
hate you for all time that's just a
classic feminist stats we'll tell you
whether you can ever get to the point
where we will forgive you for being part
of the class of men but for right now we
hate you and we will continue to hate
you as you grovel before us and try to
make amends for the original sin of
maleness and that's just classic now
imagine that this woman she's not you
know they always talk about in cells in
self forums men's rights forums and how
they express hatred towards women all
that sort of thing this woman
sorry go ahead go ahead I was just yeah
you know this woman
she is a very very important powerful
woman she's a sociologist she's a gender
studies professor she was at the time
anyway the editor of science journal
which is very important feminist Journal
she teaches students hundreds of
students every year
and she spews this kind of hate imagine
being a man in her class and knowing she
hates all men imagine being a colleague
of hers a male colleague and she's
voting on your promotion or tenure like
it it's it's and she's just one there's
a woman named Christine Fair forget what
university she's at
um she wrote about uh
uh her tweets are quite famous she
absolutely hates you know Mega hats she
Compares them to uh I don't know
statements of male Supremacy and she
said during the uh remember when Brett
Kavanaugh
um the the hearings the Senate hearings
for his confirmation to the U.S Supreme
Court was going on and he was being
accused by Christine blasey Ford of
having you know when he was 16 years old
allegedly assaulted her or tried to
assault her at a party and this woman
Christine Fair
tweeted that
any man who voted for Brett Kavanaugh
should be killed should have his
genitals cut off and fed to pigs
you know and that that's just that that
that kind of that level of hatred
especially around the metoo movement you
know when all of that was going on in
2017 and 2018
that's just standard at universities
um the University of Regina had a
um
what was it called a toxic masculinity
no it's called a masculinity confession
booth that they set up where men were
supposed to go to confess their sins of
toxic masculinity
I thought it was a joke at first you
know I thought it was an anti-feminist
joke
I want to go not that recent it was I
think in 2017 some something around
there 2018. they're giving me good
content I'm gonna cover some of these
I mean it's just it's so incredible
um I mean I I've like documented all
this stuff over the years there was a
professor
at uh St Mary's University uh in in
Eastern Canada named Judy Haven she
actually made a serious proposal that in
all University classes in Canada it
should be policy that women be called on
first
and so they they should be allowed to
speak first in every University
classroom because women's voices were
being silenced allegedly and you know
men would have to be would have to just
take second class status and maybe speak
only when all the women had finished uh
there were professors there's one at the
University of Alberta a woman named uh
Liz gottel who involved herself in a
campaign with the RCMP called don't be
that guy and it was a series of posters
allegedly telling young men because
they're so stupid and so brutish and so
crude in their thinking and behavior
telling them things like if a woman is
passed out drunk you shouldn't have sex
with her
and they you know they would have these
crude statements like just because you
helped her home doesn't mean you get to
help yourself and it would show a woman
was Brock Turner innocent
oh Brock Turner I did a video on him
well nobody knows
um you know it was a case where it was
reported that he had sexually assaulted
a woman while she was passed out behind
a dumpster after uh or you know out
outside of a a frat house that was the
the uh reporting so everybody said well
hey that's a very clear-cut case of
sexual assault she's passed out he's he
has sex with her obviously he's a he's a
brute and he should be locked away for
the next 20 years the actual facts of
the case don't support that at all he
was discovered lying with this woman
outside the frat house not behind a
dumpster I don't think by two cyclists
who were coming by and you know saw
something and yelled at him and he
got up and went running because two huge
guys were charging at him and that was
taken as proof that he was guilty in
fact he never sexually assaulted her uh
he seems to have had to have digitally
penetrated hers in other words he you
know had his finger on her vagina and
that's it
yes so it wasn't quite as you know still
if she was passed out and you know he's
he's fingering her I suppose you could
say that wasn't a good thing to do but
the the reality of it was it was so much
more complicated than that that's the
dumpster well exactly the The Narrative
was that she got so drunk that she was
you know slurring her words and couldn't
speak and he somehow hauled her outside
because he wanted to assault her and
then proceeded to assault this before
incapacitated girl the reality as far as
I could tell I read all the police
reports I read all the witness
statements like nobody saw him taking a
passed out girl you know out of the
party and you know dragging her out
everybody saw him and her together they
were both drinking
she was
drunk it seems but
that you know he was drunk too it seems
as if what happened was that the two of
them were drunk at this party they went
outside to make out they I don't know
what you know collapsed together in a
drunken Heap while they were kissing and
fondling Etc and it's quite possible
that at that point she
kind of you know went to sleep passed
out Etc who knows what I mean that that
is known to happen sometimes even the
best of us fall asleep while we're
kissing and fondling if it's really late
at night and we've had a few drinks so
you know the fat and he was drunk
himself
who nobody knows when exactly she passed
out and that is obviously of the issue
if she passed out after the cyclist came
along and saw what was you know saw
these two people together then he wasn't
sexually assaulting her at all it was
two drunken young people
having you know something and so yeah
the idea that he would have to
uh register as a sex offender for 10
years that means
you know any employer can look him up
and see that there he is I mean his name
of course is is all over the Internet uh
he'll never live this down it's gonna be
with him forever
um
yeah like nobody knows the details like
she claims that she completely blacked
out so she doesn't remember any of it
but you know a lot of people who drink a
lot do blackout but that doesn't mean
that they weren't quite
um like
quite like not drunk acting if you know
what I mean like like if you drink a lot
regularly you can black out but people
who conversed with you at the time
wouldn't necessarily think you were that
drunk so that's quite possible too he
had no reason to think that
she wasn't consenting that she wasn't
interested in him and you know it just
this one's on the news Larry Nassar
is uh is he the um no I don't I don't
know that I don't think I know that case
is he the the gymnast coach yeah yeah
yeah I don't that one I don't I don't
know as well I never looked into that in
in as much detail so so I couldn't
comment on it
Weinstein
yeah Weinstein well everybody has an
opinion on Weinstein right I mean what
can you say about that these were women
who had
um long-term relationships with him
one of them like I once I I researched
this they had long-term relationships
with him yes one one of them in
particular I researched this at the time
but it was a number of years ago so I I
can't recall the exact details but one
of them like they have a whole history
of her you know sending him emails love
you big guy you know things like that
um long after the alleged rape
she continued to see him regularly she
told friends about you know how much she
enjoyed spending time with him
um I think this the same is for the
other Accuser
so if these were cases where well it
just seems pretty obvious that this was
transactional sex of some sort
and that
those women who later you know in some
cases many years after the fact claimed
that it was a sexual assault that it
meant something quite different in the
moment wow he was an extremely powerful
man obviously anyone who wanted to work
in one of his movies
would have known that
having sex with him or at least
flirting with him Etc was a route to
success in Hollywood and the opportunity
to work in one of his films like I don't
think after the fact that that kind of
transactional sex where the women made
it clear to him that they were very
interested in what he had to offer them
and he made it clear to them that he was
interested in what they had to offer him
I don't see how that can be
reinterpreted after the fact you know
sometimes 10 years 15 years after the
fact as sexual assault for which a man
should have to spend years and years in
prison I I yeah I just find that
incredible
and and what one thing that was really
interesting to me about that story
um was again like all the feminist
justifications oh you know these women
they had no choice uh if they wanted to
work in his movies they had to sleep
with him everybody knew that was the way
it was it was a terrible thing but you
know it shouldn't be allowed to stand
um I mean they did have a choice uh
working in one of his movies wasn't
their only option in life
and again they they have they always
have to lie about things like the fact
that of the long-term relationship sort
of
it to me completely invalidates the
claim that this was a sexual assault and
they brought in uh a woman named Barbara
ziv
a forensic psychiatrist
to claim that when women's stories of
rape don't fit the standard narrative we
should make all sorts of excuses for
those women she claims that rape trauma
causes women to behave in ways that seem
inconsistent with victimization but we
shouldn't therefore conclude that they
were willing or that they weren't
victims so basically ziv's feminist
interpretation is that when women lie
when their stories keep changing when
they continue to associate
affectionately and lovingly with the man
they claim raped them when they do all
of these things that might lead us to
conclude that actually it wasn't rape it
was a consensual relationship
she says that whenever we encounter that
from an alleged victim we should
understand that it's her trauma that is
causing her to lie have an inconsistent
story or maintain a loving relationship
with the man she says raped her that's
the stage at which we have arrived in
feminist reasoning so there is
absolutely nothing that a an alleged
rape victim can do that would convince
anyone according to the feminist story
that should convince us that she's lying
in fact if she you know if her story
doesn't make straight make any sense
that's proof
that she's a rape victim
so you know it's heads you in Tales I
lose uh you know except for the
feminists it's it's that their story is
always the one that should stand and
yeah I don't know how you can take
seriously
a movement that's founded on those kinds
of profound contradictions but
people do and and the interesting thing
is that that's always been the way I
would really encourage anybody who's
interested in the history of feminism
and critique of feminism to read a guy
named Ernest Belfort backs he was a
journalist uh a barrister and a
socialist in the late 19th century in
England and he wrote a whole bunch of
essays and two books about feminism one
was called the fraud of feminism and the
other was called the legal subjection of
men they're both fascinating books one
published in the late 19th century I
think 1896 the other published in the
early 20th century 1913 or thereabouts
in the legal subjection of men he argues
that it's men who are discriminated
against in law especially in marriage
and he was you know he was a barrister
he saw all sorts of court cases and his
point he was arguing in response to John
Stuart Mill who published a book called
The subjection of women in 1869 and so
Bax was saying you know all these
complaints by women about marriage and
how women are turned into property and
they don't have any rights in marriage
he said it's the exact opposite as far
as he could tell it was Men Who
surrendered their own autonomy in
marriage and he gave all sorts of
examples of how the law was biased not
against women but in favor of women he
talked about a whole variety of crimes
that women couldn't even be prosecuted
for because there was just no interest
in Prosecuting women for certain types
of crimes and especially in marriage for
example a woman could not be prosecuted
for slandering her husband or libeling
her husband whereas if a man slandered
or liable to his wife he would be
prosecuted he made the point that in
cases of domestic violence a woman could
do nearly anything to her husband and he
would only be laughed at if he attempted
to go to police he said that if a woman
set her husband on fire most people
would believe that he deserved it and if
he went to the police about it at most
they would Levy a fine against his wife
and he would have to pay the fine
because of course a husband was
responsible for all his life's debts
many men went to debtors prison because
they were unable to pay their wives
debts that was the kind of
responsibility that a man took on in
marriage uh he talked about the fact
that if a woman murdered her husband
she usually got off because she would
claim that her husband had been abusive
if a man murdered his wife it wouldn't
matter you know same in the 1800s this
kind of stuff yes he's talking about the
the late 1800s and so that's the
fascinating thing we always think oh
maybe the pendulum has swung too far in
the 19th century in the 1800s women were
discriminated against in law now men are
discriminated against in law no that's
what Bax is saying men have men ever had
the upper hand in law
well uh you know that it that's a
complicated very complicated question uh
yeah it it the the feminist claim is
that when husband and wife when a man
and woman married and they became one
person that the man had the upper hand
in you know in various ways and there
were issues uh you know like the the
issue of uh a woman's property in
marriage
um that fluctuated throughout the 1800s
women got more and more rights over any
property that they brought into marriage
as the century developed and as feminist
Advocates pressed their case so
um men did have certain privileges at
various times but also certain
responsibilities such as the
responsibility to to look after their
wife and and to you know provide for her
even if she left him this is a point
that vax makes uh if a woman left a man
for whatever reason he still bore the
responsibility of paying her debts and
looking after her so there were all
sorts of ways that
um you know men had these legal
responsibilities that that women didn't
have and the other point that Bax makes
um
yeah I mean you know he he describes the
whole climate of opinion
about men and women and and how
um like the society simply could not
take women's uh crimes or misdoings
seriously it did not
it just it couldn't believe that when
women did wrong
that they were really responsible
and so he he points out that that
um infanticide the killing of
babies under one year old was a common
crime that women committed and yet yes
um there's one um Professor uh Pauline
Pryor at the University of Belfast a
professor of social policy
she's done a paper uh on
um women being tried for the crime of
infanticide she points out that it it
was such a common crime
in the United Kingdom the United States
as well uh that some
sociologists estimate that
61 percent of all homicides in in the
1800s were of children under one year
old and the vast majority of the killers
of those children were their mothers
wow and yeah and juries were very
reluctant to convict women of this crime
because they felt sorry for them you
know they would
and many of the women were probably
quite pitiable they were poor women some
of them were not married
um but many of them were married but the
just like the difficulty on the part of
the public of believing in female evil
was very very deeply entrenched so the
woman would always be able to make a
defense that either
um she was desperate you know she was in
a desperate situation of some sort and
that led her to commit the crime or she
wasn't in her right mind that was a you
know the temporary insanity kind of
Defense she didn't know what she was
doing and in many many cases in the
majority of cases the woman would be
acquitted of the crime because uh juries
all male juries
couldn't bear the thought of sending a
woman to prison and often you know they
felt very sorry for and this didn't only
apply to women who were unwed mothers
there were many women who were married
and who who killed their children as
well and uh they were very rarely
convicted so much like what is it like
what is it with us
Yeah well yeah I don't know that's
that's a big thing yeah yeah and and you
know even in those days
um feminists came to the defense of the
killers rather than the defense of the
babies so although feminists always put
themselves forward as as you know women
who had greater empathy for children Etc
were by Nature more nurturing than men
uh when women committed those types of
crimes they would make up excuses for
for why they did or argue that they
hadn't known what they were doing
Etc so so the the moral double standard
that we notice in our own Society now uh
was very much active then too women were
supposed to be morally Superior to men
less violent you know more empathetic
Etc but at the same time when they
committed crimes they were thought to be
not responsible for them and that's the
same today if you read um you know
there's a really interesting study by a
woman
she's a law professor at um
the University of Michigan I think and
her name is anyway I don't can't
remember where she is exactly but her
name is Sonia Starr s-t-a-r-r she wrote
a definitive study in 2013 of
criminal the gender gap in criminal
sentencing and found that women on
average for the same crimes and she did
all sorts of calculating you know to
determine what qualified as a similar
crime
but for the same crimes as men commit
women are sentenced 60 percent lighter
than men
so uh and and that that's only at the
sentencing Point she also found that
women are far less likely than men to be
arrested in the first place far less
likely than men to be charged in the
first place if they are charged they're
far more likely to be able to have the
charges dismissed or to strike some sort
of plea deal and they're far more likely
than men to be um like to to serve
um what's it called when you don't
actually go to jail like you serve a
suspended sentence you do community
service or something like that so the
the gender disparity in in the criminal
justice system is massive and that's why
we have you know 95 of the prison
population being male and even then if
you put into Google
uh like a phrase like
um program to keep women out of prison
you'll you'll find all sorts of
newspaper articles and organizations
that are dedicated to keeping women out
of prison even though that percentage of
women in prison is like a tiny
proportion of that of men and almost
nobody cares about keeping man out of
prison uh so we just have this idea in
society that
women's violence doesn't it's not a
concern I don't know they're just you
know we just have trouble taking
seriously
female evil and that was another thing I
wanted to just end with um backs just to
go back to very briefly
in in the fraud of feminism he talks
about how what you know it irritated him
so much that women were able to
literally get away with murder
and make all these claims against men
and that both men and women tended to
believe them just like now
um you know women always have had
greater in-group empathy for other women
and men have more empathy for women than
they have for other men so that's why
feminism has succeeded so you know
beyond anybody's imaginings and Belfort
backs made the point that there is this
contradiction in feminist claims that
runs right through all feminist advocacy
there's two different basic arguments on
the one hand women will say women are
equal to men we deserve equality and
whenever there is any kind of disparity
in outcomes that's because of sexism and
we demand that that disparity be
addressed we still hear this all the
time now so in the few you know stem
Fields where men still outnumber women
feminists will come forward and say this
is a clear example of sexism we need to
get more women into biochemistry they
never say anything of course about the
fact that in the education faculty women
outnumber men
you know eight to two
um
so so there's that the equality argument
he called that the political feminism
but on the other side there's always
this sentimental feminism as he called
it which is the argument that women are
different from men and they deserve to
be treated with you know special kid
gloves with special empathy with a
special understanding for their
difficult circumstances with a you know
special intention to help them more than
we would tend to help men so how can the
two of them you know are women equal or
are women special and different and
requiring special treatment well
feminism always has it both ways and
we're in the pickle we're in today
partly because of that
no I think the feminists really just
want equal prisoning sentences they're
really dying to do the plumbing the
electricity
it's yeah it's so so crazy they're just
very eager I I'm waiting the for the
Blondie on Pierce Morgan to apply next
door I've got her an interview and
everything
very good yeah
well yeah no they're just not interested
in real equality and yeah you know
that's that's
um it you know it is just maddening it
really is and and you realize when you
argue with any of these people like on
Twitter or in in an interview situation
like you had with Pierce Morgan
like they they
they're not even they don't even try to
argue in good faith they they just fall
back on these standard claims uh well
men invented X or you know men control X
so men should have to do whatever like
you know after the Titanic sank and you
know there was this huge loss of life of
of men and uh you know and so many men
had accepted their burden as men to die
so that some women could get on the
lifeboats
some you know some people paid tribute
to men for sure and said you know this
is an example of why men
um why we live in a patriarchy because
men do bear this this special kind of
responsibility but many feminists said
look if women were in charge of the the
ship and I'm not kidding you there there
are on record there's a fascinating
um study of the cultural history of the
Titanic some feminist journalists
actually wrote and said it was Men Who
Built that ship so naturally it should
have been men who died and if women were
building ships women would build them
much better than men because women care
more about saving lives and women would
have made sure that there were you know
there was nothing wrong with that ship
and it would never have gone down like
they literally wrote that in response
because they couldn't stand
the
occasion of having to acknowledge male
self-sacrifice
and you know that it gets so much the
the victim mentality because when you
have that victim mentality and like you
know researchers have studied this that
you get so into your own identity as a
victim
that you literally
are become incapable of feeling empathy
for anybody outside your particular
victim group and you can see that in all
of these feminist Advocates throughout
history you know from 200 years ago to
today that they had that inability to
feel empathy so they could almost well
they could literally kill somebody in
the out group and still see themselves
as the victims that was the other thing
that um back said too that he was always
struck by because you know he observed
many many many criminal trials in his in
his role as a as a barrister and he said
that he was always struck by the fact
that female criminals much more than
male criminals always had this air of
injured innocence even when it was
obvious that they had done the crime
they would almost never admit it they
would always blame someone else they
always felt that people were out to get
them and that you know they were being
unjustly persecuted he said most male
criminals
you could get them to admit that they'd
done wrong
but there was this sort of disordered
morality this this conviction of
immaculate
you know Perfection on the part of these
female criminals
that they somehow could avoid admitting
to themselves what they'd done and I
think I don't know whether that's
something that women are more vulnerable
to that even while we're always
proclaiming how we're more empathetic
Etc that actually we may have a
more disordered sense of
moral standards or we tend to excuse
ourselves for wrongdoing more easily I'm
not I you know I believe that I I'll
tell no that hundreds of women
anything anything that makes women look
bad there's always an excuse I've done
shows on this when did the excuses run
out
when is it just this is a bad choice
it's always well why did she cheat well
why did she divorce him well why I guess
it's never
yeah that probably wasn't a good move
it's always like I don't know what it is
but it's like the gut reaction of women
is to blame someone else I I believe
that yeah
and and it seems like society as a whole
AIDS in a bets that yeah tendency
because I've noticed that too like you
know if a man commits a horrific murder
if he murders especially if it's one of
those family murders he kills his wife
and his children
nobody
tries to offer any kind of mitigating
circumstances or excuse for him and and
yeah nobody does and anybody if anybody
even attempts to do so there was a case
in Australia
a couple years ago I think where a man
um he said his his
um locked his family his wife and I'm
not sure how many kids in the car and
set the car on fire is a horrific crime
and
um it turned out that there had been
some kind of
there was an upcoming divorce and he
knew he was probably going to lose
custody of his children so there was
kind of a mitigate I mean it's no excuse
obviously but there was that as the
context for what he did but when
um
a few people suggested that even a
particular police officer made some
reference to that and then he was
immediately attacked and he had to walk
it back and you know all that you're not
allowed to have any empathy at all for a
man who commits a horrific crime like
that but on the other side like when
women do the exact same thing
there's this rush to find all the
circumstances she had to have been
mentally ill why didn't anybody notice
why didn't anybody help her we need to
put mechanisms in place so that we can
recognize and help these women when they
you know
you know Carrie Underwood
I don't know that one actually there's a
hit song about her like um breaking her
boyfriend's car and like digging like
like she keyed his car and like yeah
and like it's mainstream nobody even
said anything but if a guy did that to a
girl it's like everyone ready arms
yes crazy controlling even if she did
like they wouldn't care because it was
all about she can do whatever she wants
because he cheated but it's like because
he cheated right yeah no there's always
the double standards if a woman cheats
like I've read articles if a woman
cheats it's because you know she she's
not her needs aren't being met
so she's the victim and uh you know
that's that's a liberating thing and you
know suddenly
um a woman's sexual needs or emotional
needs uh you know she has a right to
have those Mets whereas in the case of a
man of course if a man has unmet sexual
needs well that's just too bloody bad
you know that makes him uh a loser and
we certainly don't have any kind of
empathy for for a loser male I mean I'm
always so struck by that with all the
discussion about in cells and in cell
violence
people think it's like I got 1.5 million
subscribers in a year and everyone's
convinced they're all in cells
and it's so crazy it's like you think
1.5 million people are just in cells
like because we talk about men's issues
yeah it's crazy oh they're just yeah who
can't talk to women it's a cope really
well and that's so interesting you know
I like that why is that the go-to slur
like why why even if it were the case
that you had 1.5 million in cells who
were signing up which you know well so
like you know so why like what's wrong
with that why why is it a slur that
there is a significant number of young
men who rightly or wrongly figure
they're never going to have a girlfriend
and that they're going to be celibate
all their lives and they don't want to
be and they're angry about that and
frustrated with that situation why why
why is that something to laugh about I
mean I I just I find the you know again
yeah like it's both a lack of empathy
and more than that like it's hatred and
yeah if like I've read so many articles
about the alleged Threat by in cells you
know who are allegedly full of misogyny
and and they're gonna harm women
um and and the feminist perspective is
seems to be you know these terrible guys
they they figure they have they should
have a right to sex
well if it's a woman and and you know
then they do seem to speak as if a woman
has a right not only a right to sex she
has a right to have an orgasm I was
reading this ridiculous article just
recently about the orgasm Gap by these
researchers at University you know it's
essentially trying to pretend that this
is some sort of Injustice that our
society doesn't value women's sexual
pleasure so there's all that but the
meantime you've got guys made an article
about like how women are terrible at
sucking dick or something I know that
yeah no and the article was so insulting
like it did have such a clear anti-male
agenda it was suggesting that I mean
everything was wrong with men either
they they didn't know what to do to give
women pleasure because they have this
you know unrealistic sense of what
causes an orgasm feminists have sex with
these men that don't care about them and
then wonder why they're not happy it's
like well that's what happens when you
sleep with 10 men from the bar Diane I
don't know what to tell you you know
what I mean stop what now you're like
whining in an article like get out of it
I know yeah it's quite it's quite it is
remarkable like how the whole focus of
everything shifts when you're talking
about women as compared to men and you
know but their attitude to in cells is
just you know you have we have to keep
telling these men that they don't have a
right to anything they don't have a
right to happiness they don't have a
right to have a sexual partner and women
don't owe them anything let's just if we
keep telling them that that's going to
make everything okay like it's um yeah
it the
well you get the very clear sense that
that
feminists and women in general I think
actually want to see men suffer
and as bad as things get for men they'd
be happy to see them get even worse
well thank you for coming on you're like
a Fountain of Knowledge like I can tell
you've been studying this stuff forever
oh well thank you I really enjoyed
having the chance to to speak with you
about all these things
um do you want to tell the people where
they can find you if um
they want to like follow you on YouTube
or whatever
yeah I have a I have a YouTube channel
called Studio B
and uh yeah if you put Studio B fiamengo
into Google it should come up and and I
have there
um basically a history of of feminist
thought and feminist advocacy and I also
have a sub stack newsletter and I'd
really love to have people
um take out a subscription free
subscription I've got a really great
robust comment section and so that is
fiamingofile.substack.com
well thank you for coming on
um guys make sure you like the video on
your way out and subscribe to the
channel and go subscribe to her Channel
This Woman's a Fountain of Knowledge
right here
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time